[Musique]
aujourd'hui donc c'est jour de battle
graphique avec le brassard c'est une
manifestation qui est organisée tous les
ans au sein de l'ensemble de nos
établissements le but de cette journée
c'est de permettre à nos jeunes de se
confronter sur un sujet qu'ils ne
connaissent pas qu'ils vont découvrir
tout à l'heure pour cette battle prend
une dimension particulière cette année
puisqu'on est dans un contexte un peu
particulier de
decaux vide alors l'école brassard
résiste d'une certaine manière puisque
nous avons des dérogations pour
maintenir nos enseignements et pour nos
étudiants et pour nous ça avait plus de
sens encore cette année que les autres
années puisque on voulait aussi
profité de cette journée pour être un
peu festif remonter un peu le moral des
troupes reprojeter nos jeunes aussi dans
une espèce de perspectives dans une
compétition joyeuse
[Musique]
le tout de l'école ça me paraît trop
pour elle a vraiment une grosse
contrainte donc je pense acheter en main
sur autre chose mais ça permet juste de
réfléchir tu peux parler
d'écologie par exemple tu vois oui des
messages je suis parti sur l'idée d'un
théâtre d'ombrés donc en fait ça se
présenterait sous avec la fin d'un cadre
et en fond il y aurait sept silhouettes
de femmes qui a l'air un peu triste pour
en référence aussi à la détresse un peu
étudiante et dans l'idée quand on
éclairé avec une lumière juste derrière
on verrait juste la silhouette de la
femme donc en fait les personnages
s'effacerait complètement et en fait
c'est tout à fait en accord avec ce
qu'on vit en ce moment avec la détresse
sociale avec eux l'effet de solitude
aussi et l'effet de renfermement dans un
espace clos juste avec quatre murs en
fait pour toucher les gens il faut faire
passer un message et je pense que le
meilleur message qu'on peut passer c'est
celui qu'on ressent le plus en ce moment
donc les jardins que le fait que les
directeurs extra essayer de faire en
sorte que ans soit le maximum en course
était déjà c'est déjà un acte de
résistance mais mes ouailles fait qu'on
se retrouve tous ensemble s'ajoute un
petit peu de peps c'est sympa je partis
sur une espèce de composition avec des
éléments qui émane de la tête d'un
personnage qui dort donc
où ça on imagine que ses rêves en gros
en fait vu que la lumière vient de
devant elle elle est en arrière après
les rencontres jour pardon donc il doit
y avoir ce petit livret qui dessine son
contour c'est une super bouffée
d'oxygène pour les étudiants ils ont ils
ont des pressions qu'on connaît tous
entre guillemets psychologique
d'isolement etc et ils ont aussi une
obligation de résultat avec les projets
qu'on leur fait faire et aujourd'hui
c'est
c'est la récréation créative
j'ai décidé de reprendre un tableau
connu donc la naissance de vénus c'est
un tableau que tout le monde connaît et
je voulais dénoncer la pollution
maritime donc du coup je me suis dit que
j'allais transformer ce avec un style un
peu street art quelque chose de beaucoup
plus facile on va dire avec des gros
cons tour des couleurs des aplats de
couleurs
[Musique]
y a un peu peiné à trouver une idée mais
au final je veux jouer avec les
contrastes et jouer avec des techniques
que je maîtrise un peu mieux que sur
ordinateur etc et en moins le thème je
suis parti un peu sur les démons
intérieurs qu'on peut avoir à vous de
jouer le contraste entre aux couleurs
extérieures et là du coup dans la fumée
elle était triste mais je vous rappeler
sur les démons qu'on peut renfermer
[Musique]